- [Voiceover] Part C, evaluate
the second derivative of y
with respect to x squared
at the point on the curve
where x equals negative one
and y is equal to one.
Alright, so let's just go to the beginning
where they tell us
that dy dx is equal to
y over three y squared
minus x.
So let me write that down.
So dy
dy dx is equal to
y over three y squared
minus x.
Three y squared minus x.
And now what I wanna do is essentially,
take the derivative of both sides again.
Now, there's a bunch of ways
that we could try to tackle it,
but the way it's written right now,
if I take the derivative
of the right-hand side,
I'm gonna have to apply the quotient rule,
which is really just comes
from the product rule,
but it gets pretty hairy.
So, let's see if I can
simplify my task a little bit.
I'm going to have to do
implicit differentiation
one way or the other,
so what if I multiply both sides
of this times three y squared minus x?
Then I get three y squared minus x
times dy dx
is equal to,
is equal to y.
And so now, taking the
derivative of both sides of this
is going to be a little
bit more straightforward.
In fact, if I want,
I could,
well actually, let me
just do it like this.
And so, let's,
let's apply our derivative
operator to both sides.
Let's give ourselves some space.
So I'm gonna apply my derivative
operator to both sides.
We take the derivative
of the left-hand side
with respect to x,
and the derivative of the right-hand side
with respect to x.
And so, here I'll apply the product rule.
First, I'll take the
derivative of this expression
and then multiply that times dy dx,
and then I'll take the
derivative of this expression
and multiply it times this.
So, the derivative of
three y squared minus x
with respect to x,
well, that is going to be,
so if I take the derivative
of three y squared
with respect to y,
it's going to be six y,
and then I have to take
the derivative of y
with respect to x,
so times dy dx.
As we say,
and this is completely unfamiliar to you
and I encourage you to
watch the several videos
on Khan Academy on
implicit differentiation,
which is really just an
extension of the chain rule.
I took the derivative of three y squared
with respect to y,
and took the derivative of y
with respect to x.
Now, if I take the
derivative of negative x
with respect to x,
that's going to be negative one.
Fair enough.
And so, I took the derivative of this,
I'm gonna multiply it times that.
So times dy dx
and then to that,
I'm going to add the derivative of this
with respect to x.
Well, that's just going to
be the second derivative
of y with respect to x
times this.
And all I do is apply the product rule.
Three y squared minus x.
Once again, I'll say it a third time,
derivative of this times this
plus the derivative of this
times that.
Alright.
That's going to be equal to,
on the right-hand side,
derivative of y with respect to x
is just dy dx.
Now, if I want to,
I could solve for the
second derivative of y
with respect to x,
but what could be even better than that
is if I substitute
everything else with numbers
because then it's just going to be a nice,
easy numerical equation to solve.
So, we know that,
what we wanna figure out,
our second derivative,
when y is equal to one.
So y is equal to one.
So that's going to be equal to one
and this is going to be equal to one.
X is equal to negative one.
So, let me underline that.
So x is negative one.
Are there any other xs here?
And what's dy dx?
Well, dy dx,
dy dx
is going to be equal to
one over three times one,
which is three,
minus negative one.
So, this is equal to one fourth.
In fact, that's I think where
we evaluated in the beginning.
Yep, at the point negative one comma one.
At the point negative one comma one.
So that's dy dx is one fourth.
So this is one fourth,
this is one fourth,
and this is one fourth.
And now, we can solve for the second
can solve for the second derivative.
Just gonna make sure I don't
make any careless mistakes.
So if six times one times one fourth
is going to be one point five,
or six,
well, six times one times
one fourth is six fourths,
minus one is going to be,
so six fourths minus four
fourths is two fourths,
so this is going to be one half
times one fourth,
that's this over here,
plus the second derivative of y
with respect to x,
and here I have one minus negative one,
so it's one plus one,
so times two.
So maybe I'll write it this way.
Plus two times
the second derivative of y
with respect to x
is equal to one fourth.
And so let's see,
I have one eighth
plus two times the second derivative
is equal to one fourth.
And let's see,
I could subtract one
eighth from both sides.
So let's subtract one eighth.
Subtract one eighth.
These cancel.
I get two times the second derivative of y
with respect to x
is equal to,
one fourth is the same
thing as two eighths,
so two eighths minus one
eighth is one eighth.
And then I can divide both sides by two,
and we get a little bit
of a drum roll here,
we divide both sides by two,
or you could say multiple
both sides times one half,
and you are going to get,
you are going to get
the second derivative of y
with respect to x
when x is negative one
and y is equal to one,
is one over 16.
And we're done.